[موسيقى]
هذا الجدل دفعنا الى ام الدنيا في مصر
سالنا الناس ما رايك في موجه الغضب تجاهه
نتفليكس كليوباترا لبطله لبطله سمراء
اللون كانت في الفيلم ماذا
[موسيقى]
ان الكلام ده اصلا كله غلط لان الناس كلها
اتضايقت بسبب الموضوع ده عشان المصريين
اصلا مش قليل من الناس دي ولا
تاريخ مش بتاعهم كليوباترا المفروض احسن
من كده بكتير يعني
كليوباترا بتحكي عن حضاره مصر
فالمفروض يعني كانت الصوره تبقى احسن من
كده يعني لان طبعا دي حضاره مصر وحضاره
البلد لازم
نهتم بها احسن من كده بكتير بيزيفوا
الحقايق يعني هم عاوزين يطلعوها مثلا
افريقيه او انها مش من اصول مصريه او انها
اي حاجه تاني
انما هم مش عاوزين يعترفوا بان مصر هي ام
الحضارات ومش عاوزين يعترفوا ان مصر هي
منبع لحضراتكم هو مش عنصريه كانت اللون بس
كان في الحمله اللي معموله اللي هو انتوا
بتاخذوا تاريخنا احنا بس ما هو اصلا كانوا
مصريين هو كل المصريين حطوا
حطوا كل الناس اسمر اللون ما حطوش اي حاجه
تدور لان دول المصريين بس
دي متابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات